here's just a wild wild report from
vanity Fair's best Levin Donald Trump
thought he could sue Congress for
impeaching him he thought he could sue
Congress because as legislators they
impeached him now what's not clear is
whether he thought he could sue Congress
as an institution or that he could sue
the individual members who voted to
impeach and later in the Senate to
convict you know with Trump it's never
really clear what he means this entire
article is worth reading
um uh by best Levin and the key part is
actually from Maggie haberman's
forthcoming book confidence man which
says
uh when the house introduced articles of
impeachment against Trump for the first
time in 2019 Trump reacted with a
familiar refrain according to the book
I'll just Sue Congress they can't do
this to me best Levin adds it's not
clear whether Trump responded similarly
after the second impeachment articles
though there's probably a 50 chance that
he did listen this would not really be a
shock to anybody who's been following
the I guess we would call them trials
and tribulations of trump he thought
that pulling in a special Master after
the Mar-A-Lago search warrant was going
to be good for him and it did not work
out out that way
he looked directly into the Sun during
that Eclipse even though he was told not
to I mean like at the micro level and
the macro level he always believes
things that aren't true and believes
certain things would be good for him
that actually are not what's
particularly funny about Trump thinking
he can sue Congress is that right now we
talked about this yesterday on the bonus
show the argument that Trump's lawyers
are making to get a defamation suit
against Trump dismissed is that the
defendant should actually be the
government and not Trump and so you have
this extraordinary situation where on
the and and the point is you can't sue
the government for defamation so its
defamation versus the impeachment but on
the one hand in court Trump's lawyers
are arguing you can't go after the
government for defamation and really e
Gene Carroll's gripe is with the
government and not with Trump even
though it was Trump who said the things
that are allegedly defamatory and
meanwhile after and during the
impeachment Trump was saying well I'll
just sue the government as if that's
something you can do over a legislative
Duty that Congress has which is to
consider whether a president has done
something worthy of impeachment it's all
it it's all completely scrambled you all
know that and the other theme to this is
the things that are said publicly in the
court of public opinion by Trump and
even sometimes by his lawyers don't
translate to what they actually try to
argue in court these are two different
things and likewise nobody's going to
sue Congress for carrying out an
impeachment and of course it didn't
happen we will see what ultimately comes
of 2024 but best Levin sort of raising
the alarm here and saying listen
the election stuff was not the only
wacky dangerous unhinged stuff that
Donald Trump was thinking at that time
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
delivered right to your door with fresh
organic baby food for every stage
toddler and kids meals that even the
picky eaters will love and the new line
of healthy smoothies little spoon has
you covered little spoon makes
everything fresh it's just like homemade
it's ready in mere moments all of the
recipes are delicious they're
nutritionally balanced and free of junk
little spoons baby food is 100 organic
and cold pressed for every eating stage
for toddlers and kids little spoon has
the classics mac and cheese but they'll
sneak things in like butternut squash
and carrots they have more adventurous
meals cheesy pupusas or chicken pot
stickers they're all kid approved packed
with nutrients and little spoons organic
smoothies are perfect perfect when you
need something quick and easy and the
best part is kids meals under six
dollars and baby food and smoothies
under three dollars each plus you'll get
fifty percent off your first order when
you go to littlespoon.com and use the
coupon code Pacman 50. the link is down
below